hi everyone
um well yeah so my name is Karina and I
work at face it's for solutions and what
we do is we work with eSports so dota
League of Legends counter-strike may be
a third of them maybe you also know
there's a huge businesses are growing
traditional sports and what we do is we
have data exchange platform and we have
an expose directory with rock matches
and finally we predict who is going to
win and convert it to betting odds and
the part about betting odds is where we
actually need the ratings and my family
data scientists base we have four data
centers currently and we are growing
very rapidly so what are we talking
about here a scale rating we're going to
say is an estimation of the true scale
of a competitor from the observed
competition results and to give you an
outline what we're going to do if we're
going to talk a lot about ratings mostly
about the ELA rating then we're going to
talk about liquor little less and very
briefly talk about true scale and what a
Sega will be our example so if you came
here for details about true scale or for
details about liquor - then I'm not
upset if you leave unfortunately this is
luxury talk so we're going to be
focusing on the basics so introduction
why do we need accurate ratings at all
well in my business we need them to
predict major outcomes but another very
cool application which comes with mass
outcomes is that we can use them to
predict earth upsets so if we have the
ranking of every single team in the
world then we can look at how big was
the difference between ranks and then
see oh man they should never have won
but they did like for example South
Korea against Germany some of you might
remember this happened a year ago and
this is actually I think number three
upset on this list or it or historically
so if you look here at the ratings
difference this was pretty bad we can
also use ratings for qualifications for
tournaments so you have to be at least
this good in order to participate and of
course this also gives me as a player or
as a team an incentive to improve my
performance because if I can measure it
against other people's performance as an
attainment it's fine to talk about
ratings it's fun to look at this table
and finally in online video games so
last 20 years
we need ratings in order to balance our
messages and this is a very hot topic
because if you go online and you look at
ratings then people will be complaining
all the time and most people will be
complaining without actually
understanding what they're complaining
about because they don't know how that
goes so what are the requirements for
eating's first of all they have to be
easy to use your normal matchmaker will
take one maybe two values they will not
take a distribution they were not taking
ensemble method or whatever else you
have they have to be very easy to tune
because normally people who run the
league and not mathematicians so they
will mess it up if it's so complicated
and they have to of course give a good
prediction of match outcome this is
actually how we evaluate our writing
algorithms and they have to converge
fast because if you launch a new game
and you have unranked players all over
the place and it takes you a month to
convert nobody will be playing anymore
because everybody will be smashed and
once you have established ratings it
should still be easier to add new
players because again and you play I
want to have a good experience and not
be mismatched for the first twenty
thirteen matches on the other hand for
established players we want to have no
summation of ratings so even if I'm
already very very good and very very
leveled every single mesh will still
have an impact on my rating and finally
they have to be hard to manipulate by
gaming the system so for example if
we're playing a video game and I'm
getting points for self-healing I'll
just going to be standing in a quad
damaging myself and healing myself and
that's also not a good rating algorithm
mathematically what we can say why are
we talking about patient ratings we are
going to assume that we have a skill
that is unknown but it's drawn from a
distribution and normally we'll use
logistic and after each match the team's
skill will change by an unknown amount
then that you will play a match and the
real performance will be exhibited and
we can update our posterior distribution
with this result so how it looks in real
life is we have for example here the
prior distribution then our player or
team will pay
assemblé matches and they will here they
have one applaud because their rating
has increased at the same time the scale
of the logistic has decreased so we have
become we have become more certain about
this killer and so what do we need to do
when you want to have a written
algorithm we have to first choose a
distribution then able to choose the
parameters of the distribution and then
we will have to find an update rule how
to handle match results and one very
simple and very famous approach is
yellow so he who here has an ill rating
and knows that you lay ill rating quite
a lot of fever cool so Hilo comes from
chess it was created by a chess player
mathematician apart illo already in the
60s and it's very common now it's been
about is the most traditional sports and
you'll find it in chess and baseball and
basketball you will also find it on the
social network movie where they're
creating the face face smash algorithm
and comparing hotness of girls and as
we'll see in next slide this formula is
actually from so yellow layer starts
with a fixed amount of pointers initial
rating and their true player still is
approximated by logistic distribution
around the rating with a scale X which s
which is fixed and then they play
against a player B who has their own
rating B with the same scale and we
calculate the expected outcome of a
versus B with this formula here so where
does this come from it probably looks
familiar to most of you because this is
our logistic CDF so we have a ranking so
logistic here and if we just substitute
these s by this expression we will make
it into something which is e to the
power which is 10 to the power of of
something else and if in a substitute
the mu with the ranking of our opponent
then we arrive with this formulation
here so we essentially we are evaluating
the converted distribution function of
our opponent at our own ranking and
what's interesting here is if you look
at this if this here is exactly equal to
n so if our difference in points is
exactly n then we have here 1 over 11
and this means that our chance of
winning is 10% so opponent will win 10
out of 11 games and this is the meaning
of n
in this formula so n defines a power of
10 in skill so if you have an e law of a
thousand and grandmother has an in-law
of 2,500 then you have a 1 in a I think
10,000 chance of winning good luck
so here for example we have a little
difference of 200 and we arrived about
monk water probability of winning so
going back to our ello we now have our
rankings we have a way of computing our
settlement probability and now we pray a
real match and we have a real outcome
which we just say is 1 if we win it's
0.5 if we lose it's if you draw and 0 if
I lose and now we do our rating update
simply by saying our new rating is our
old rating plus the difference of our
expected outcome manager and the real
outcome scale button effect ok and this
K is the most important part of the
algorithm because again if we just look
at I didn't think about it let's say we
predicted this player is going to
certainly win almost 0 and they want
almost to certainly lose if it's almost
0 and they won so here we have won and
the ranking will be updated by exactly K
points so in other words case all
sensitivity and this means if we choose
K it has to be prepared for n because if
we give the player end points every time
they have an upset then their ranking
will jumping around a lot and also K
should be appropriate for the match
format so if we have a lot of games in
the season and it's ok to lose one game
so for example in baseball even the best
team will lose like 1/3 of the game and
then K should be small and one match but
affect the ratings as much on the other
hand if we are in FL or in college
basketball's and every match matters
because the fewer measures it's ok
should be large we can also basically on
experience so for example in chess we'll
have k equal to 44 new players so the
rankings will just will change faster
then if they have played 30 games but
they've never been a great master level
then k will be decreased or 20 and then
everyone else here are the very top
players and they will have K 10 so again
this means that if a Grandmaster loses
to somebody who's a new player than the
new players renting will go up for 40
points but the Grandmaster will only
lose ten which makes sense because
they're an established player they
should not be punished as much in
football we will have for a world for
the national team rankings will have 60
for the World Cup because everybody's
playing very very seriously then 40 for
the qualifiers and then we go down until
the friendly matches or maybe not even
the a team is going to be on the field
and we have K equals 20 but again
because they have fewer football matches
than we have chess matches the total
scale of K is greater and as promised
wooden Sega so I chose to teens I just
buy on because everybody knows they're
very strong established team in fact we
see them winning the bonus they are
quite a lot here and that just ain't a
fun sport mainly because it's my
friend's favorite team and so we have
three variants of K here we have k equal
to 10 which is the default of the Python
package written by assembly and then we
have 30 and we have 60 and of course as
expected we see that for 60 the rating
jumps up and down quite a bit and for 10
it stays almost almost constant and
climbing here quite slowly and then from
this we can get our expected in
probability of an us vs. by an and this
is oscillating around 0.3 which it's up
to you if this is a good rating of it's
a bit overwhelming I interact what's
quite interesting here is a FIFO by
under all the ratings increased very
high here and around 2013 and then they
suddenly fall down and I would like you
to maybe after the shock to think about
why does this happen because if you
understand why this happens then you
have understood the ELA algorithm so in
summary the key ideas are we have a
player skill it is approximately but
it's a distribution of fixed scale the
improbability is given by the cumulative
distribution function of the logistic
and distribution mean is updated after
each match result in generating we want
to view in this we have to choose
initial rating first then we have to
choose n to choose k and then make
adjustments for our domain so we can
play around with K we can also say ok
how many baby home team s has an
advantage the home team gets less points
as they won
maybe we have a margin of victory with
an additional factor maybe in chess we
will use chess piece color so there's
really this is up to you to say domain
knowledge and it's the most important
part of working with these algorithms
speaking our tuning how do we tune well
we want to minimize the expected call
score versus the outcome we call this
the Brian score in our application early
just mean squared error the cool thing
about these algorithms is that our
entire data set is up test set because
if we just take the reasoning before the
match then we can use every single row
except we should probably ignore the
calibration period because if you look
back at this especially here in the
beginning this little bump here we don't
want to have this in our tests because
this is not an extra measure of high
rating no issue is about a low there are
quite a few so first and the main input
main one is inactivity doesn't doesn't
affect the ratings again going back to
Iraq
here and here I talked didn't even play
because they weren't in the Bundesliga
but the rating remains constant and
because of that they still try to
protect the ranking they will just only
play people where they know they will
not lose a lot of points time between
matches is not factored new players
might be overvalued again remembering I
interact if you if they have below their
new player rating and a new team comes
from a second Bundesliga then you might
argue are they really stronger by
default maybe not and minor problem is
that you have inflation and deflation of
rankings when a lot of people join or
leave it
a seen this is actually only a problem
if you want to compare historical data
because you can't and only two ratings
are updated at a time so but this is
actually not a problem because this
thing is eloah was designed to be easy
and simple and easy to understand I mean
if you just learned Tyson today you're
going to be able to write this and this
is already taking a lot more codes and
it would need to and this is our entire
algorithm and you can do this with pen
paper also but the second C do have
computers and so we can do more and this
more is called clicker
so click Oh again it's developed by
someone who call it after himself
this kid in this case my click man again
just a mathematician he then himself
improved it to be click or 2 which is
released actually quite recently it's
very well documented he has a website
just about click oh so it's super cool
to look at and you will find it's mostly
online so many video games use it
chestnut calm users let go online user
said the idea that may not have not only
the rating but also rating deviation so
the bayesian deviation will decrease
with your match results because we
become more certain about your ability
and then it will increase if you're an
active the rating itself the rating
deviation depends on volatility which is
inconsistent in your performance and the
skill of given is the confidence
interval now because we have a varying
scale so we usually use two standard
deviation social scale and one other
major innovation is that the rating
periods are not being used this means
that we take several matches and we use
them for rating at once and then release
a new rating I'm going to talk about
this in more detail so first of all what
does this red indicate mean well you
have your ranking and then you play
match your ranking changes and at the
same time our and our insecurities about
your ranking drops down but then while
you don't play it will slowly rise again
because as you don't play you don't
exhibit any results so your your the
certainty rating deviation is constantly
growing and in lico 1 this was just a
time constant so you would say ok it
should take this long for your rating to
decay back to that of an already player
it was for example in chest 10 years
anglich or true this is a bit more
complex now their rating deviation
itself was a function of another
parameter Sigma which is constrained by
some tuning parameter tau which
regulates how much your ranking can
change at once if you're going to work
with this you will get a feeling for how
tall and Sigma influenced each other so
this is really something you need to
understand yourself and the reason why
I'm not explaining it here is because
Clicquot looks like this
and here not even every single of these
letters is explained but if you look at
it from further away it's not as
complicated because again we have the
old rating and we have some K which now
is a function of a rating deviation and
our Sigma and we have then now for all
our points in the rating period and not
just for one guys before we have our
actual outcome versus minutes our
expected outcome we multiplied by some
constant which which depends on the
rating deviation of our opponents so
ultimately we're still taking the error
between our prediction and our outcome
and giving some points to our final
rating we just doing it a bit more
complex more dynamic fashion here's the
cool example that I stole from this very
very good paper that I recommend you to
read Grandmaster gata Kamsky was
somebody who was I think rent ranked top
four in the world and then he lost
through I think Kasparov and quit chess
for several years and came back so the
elo stays constant for the entire time
the Clicquot also stays constant because
the rating itself doesn't change was
time by the rating deviation decays so
when the elo when he plays again and he
loses points the illah goes down a
little bit but the Clicquot goes down
significantly and the reason for this is
that while he wasn't playing his his
rating deviation has increased so much
and then as he plays again and his
slowly gets better again the clicker
reacts much faster going back to our
chess I would like now to talk about
this series this red rating period so
the rating period is how many games how
many how much time how many games in a
period of time are we going to take for
our rating and for soccer here I chose
three different periods I chose one day
as a period which doesn't really make
much sense because the requirement of
the algorithm is a 10 to 15 games per
team and then I chose one month and
finally one season and we can see of
course for season the rating will be
much more smooth because we took me to a
company all the games all the results
and then we get lot more deviation in
the monthly and even motiviation is a
in the daily but what's actually more
interesting to look at is our Sigma in
town so as an intuition lat Sigma latch
tile means more variation in our rating
deviation and I'll than small ones so we
can see here our rating deviation and
like I said before in this part and in
this part I just did not play in the
Bundesliga and we can really see here
the cedars here you can see by these
ways
there was no no results so our ranked
our deviation is increasing and of
course and again we can see that for
greater - I think it's increasing a lot
more than these little bumps here for
very conservative values again this is
available online there's a emitted by
the same guy who did the clicker so you
can use it but remember to tune these
values first and just to remind you for
when we talk about a clicker ratings we
talk about rating and the deviation we
don't talk about just the rating
otherwise it's unfair because for
example here we can see that there was
that actually actual clicker rating
would be here and another point another
thing I want to find out is all these
measures they should not be compared to
among each other here we have the yellow
in red and then we have the three
clickers we talked about before instead
we can only use them as compared to
compare teams against each other in the
same framework so if you compete compute
the vulnerability again remember before
I said that I think that is being a bit
overrated by you know
well clicker is agreeing with me here
and in fact the most recent three
matches they lost quite devastatingly
against Bayern so in summary again the
key ideas here we have this rating
deviation we have the volatility of the
rating which depends on how well they're
performing but also decays with time and
we have rating period of several games
that we have to have so if we want to
use this first we have to choose a
rating period that fits our structure of
the of the tournaments
well choose initial values the defaults
are quite good
4.click oh one we will choose how long
ago check 482 DK formerly code 2 we will
choose how uncertain our ratings may
become and how much of an how much the
dirt and you can change within one
period and known issues here are first
of all because we have this constant
decay of rating the they only by the
time of the computation the moment they
are published they are already becoming
invalid because the rating decay is
increasing constantly and during the
rating period we only have provisional
ratings we don't have the true ratings
yet and the impact of one single match
in this whole rating period is not
transparent so we can't say okay if they
win this match they're going to be
number one because nobody knows and not
sure maybe I made it possible maybe I'll
explain it well maybe I didn't but in
general it's hard to explain especially
people don't have a math background how
much time they have left
oh okay so just kill the search
algorithm on the list
honestly in mopping in the top and it
was liquor because these are the two
ratings that give us pretty good returns
but true skill is the password when it
comes to ratings you will find it
everywhere online so I didn't want to
not include it but the thing is true
skill solves a very different problem so
what they do what they say is we have
teams online so we have players queuing
for matches online and we want to build
teams of these players which are almost
equally matched so they have can have a
matched game so like before if you
playing pickup basketball and cap and
select the teams we can't have this
online so we have to have some other way
of having balanced teams so true skill
doesn't as much care about rating
players in orders they care more about
maximizing your probability which is not
exactly the same thing so initially it
was developed for Halo but you can find
it in a lot more games now it assumes
that player skill is normally
distributed remember before we talking
about logistic and if the team's
composed about of several players then
there Tim skill the giantess the
distribution of these player skills and
as
match then the distribution of all the
players will be updated and they have a
very clever way of updating the
posterior distribution but unfortunately
this is proprietary so this is actually
my main problem with trueskill oh I
don't wanna talk about it so much
because it is fairly well documented but
there is no official package to do it
there is no official paper giving you
all the implementation details and it's
trademarked as patented you were not
allowed to use it um but if you do use
it there is a package by Young suply
again which looks pretty much correct
and there's also very good favored by
most well this is a guy who he went into
this algorithm and he went into all the
details and then summed up his findings
so the benefits of trueskill is it's
very similar pleco in functioning but it
can update after each match it converges
pretty fast for new players which is
very good because if you play online
like I said you want to have a quick
estimate as fast as possible and it has
solutions for things like partial play
or if you have several teams competing
or if you have people who quit in the
middle of the match then it can handle
that the other algorithms don't but the
shortcomings are like I said is
proprietary also if it's player base it
means that every single player now has
to have a minimal amount of games and
for example in our business we want to
predict the outcome between teams were
going to play and professional teams are
going to play so we need to know every
single player who's going to play and we
can't because maybe somebody's
grandmother died and finally it's
difficult to tune model parameters here
because especially in true skill - they
will impact will they will also take
domain-specific impact like how does it
kill right up the earth effective in
rates etc and they say the paper that
they need thousands for that in
traditional sports a thousand games are
several years sometimes so in my
personal opinion it's easier to model a
team based on the historic performance
together if they have historic
performance of course if you're modeling
top form teams than you have to use
something like true skill so in summary
rating algorithms need to be tuned
ratings algorithms need time to convert
you can't immediately use them they can
then be used to predict match outcome
and there is no best algorithm like in
any machine learning application the
best algorithm is a wonderf it's your
domain but often a law will be good
enough and if you have players who don't
play regularly then you should be
looking to play co and if you have
theirs forming teams at hoc is enough
playing together this is when you maybe
look at your skill and domain knowledge
here is better than not having a fancy
algorithm because if you have two main
knowledge then you can model your you
can model these particulars in your
algorithm just by saying how many points
are you going to give extra to somebody
yeah so this went a lot faster than
expected I have time to thank my friend
and colleague Ben Stein who's in who
runs the website that dota and does
nothing but great dota teams there and a
lot of sources they are actually quite
interesting reads if you want to look
more into this and there was a typo here
on this ratings talk but all the plots
are made here are in this repo and how
to call these packages in this repo it's
not super clean because I was writing it
as I was some presentation but you can
at least find examples of how to use the
packages
[Applause]
thank you very much so any questions yes
maybe I first go up yeah thanks a cool
talk lovely topic just out of curiosity
what's the Israeli reason why they
prefer the logistic distribution over
the Gaussian one yes good question
actually um no I don't have a set for
this but the so the if you think about
the shape the Gaussian is a bit more of
it the logistic is flatter so the tails
are thicker exactly so so you have the
chance of upsets becomes less hi thank
you for your talk the question would be
in game like daughter does this
algorithm perform the same as in Halo or
its ears because you have different
types of characters and technically
completely different skills and again
good question so first of all I have
this prepared a slide so you have the
real scores of different algorithms for
dota specifically the thing is the
algorithms don't actually fit the skills
that you need that fit the performance
of the players so the performance will
be a function of the skills that you
need for the game if you know what I
mean
so yeah they will perform the same way
but for example in true skill they do
model different game modes of Halo
differently but then they also assume
that the skills are pretty well and so
they might sometimes still use a
different game mode for tuning the the
new game mode before its release so the
other question or about tuning is there
is any specific technique how you can
tune K&N well you can write something
like your own CV for example for this
cross-validation no no specific Technic
really just have a good initial guess
see how it performs and then go from
there to my knowledge I'm interested in
the setting with
ad hoc teams forming so I just want to
ask for clarification does true skill
rank the individual players yes and you
mentioned some inconveniences with true
skill do you know of good alternatives
well there's a lot of alternatives well
first of all you can also use Clicquot
and you know in order to have these ad
hoc team so you just have to cheat a
little bit and say how your update after
the match is that you'll just distribute
this so what you will do is you will
just say we have the initial
distributions of all the different
players with that LICO for example and
then we'll say again the team is just
the John distribution another question
becomes how do we update this and we
just say ok the win is win of every
single player the same way then we can
just update them the same way as we did
before and just get a little bit more
cleverly because they don't they don't
think of how many how many minutes did
the player play etc that's the only
difference there's also an algorithm
called whole history rating where they
look at the entire performance of the
player through time where it means and
intensive and yeah so most algorithms
you find like fully gov legends for
overwatch
there will be some variations of true
skill and Glick hope is a clay I mean
true skill itself is already
defibrillation of clickers to be honest
I'm sorry another chair thank you really
nice talking's a gamer at least I know
why I'm on the bottom of the list so but
my question is it's completely out of
the topic in a sense I would like to
move the DS out of the box and ask you
would it make sense to apply these for
like medical data if you if you think of
you can come up with a function to give
a score to a pathogen or cancer
and then you give a score to the to the
patient with it or his or her medical
status and treatment applied would it
make sense to apply these algorithms to
predict the outcome of healing the
patient or not so I would have to think
about it longer but my initial feeling
is no because every cancer only plays
once and yeah so basically we don't have
a performance over time because every
patient probably is different I don't
know I have no medical background so I'm
really swimming here but I don't think
that's a good idea
but what they what they actually do is
in the volitional bowel that is a gift
true skill to monkeys so they say they
won't define the most dominant monkey by
how many I'm not I'm not sure exactly on
the details but I think it's either how
many other monkeys came to groom them
something like that so many other
curiosity are there applications of
these algorithms outside of sports and
video games well the monkey definitely
monkeys great monkeys but in industry
because I can imagine keeping track of
something over time and I well as
performing that's you know good
predictive maintenance and all that
that's great but it's but does it also
like would you be aware of any of these
other non monkey related industry I had
I had the same question actually this is
why not all the monkeys because the only
examples I could find were in sociology
and yeah I also wonder why because it's
so similar
there's one more question there okay
question sir is this correct that the
Lightning talks are canceled or what was
the keynote keynote has canceled on main
hub for your informations thank you for
the talk you mentioned in the beginning
that also part of your work is to
predict which team is gonna we not how
likely for a team is going to win and
that's how betting companies make the
odds before the match
modern betting companies also have an
in-game and all those algorithms are all
rating after the game so how is the
in-game ording getting done well once we
are in game we can use the in-game
measures of the team so we can use how
much goals they have which weapons do
they have where are they on the map etc
and this is of course a much better
indication of what's going to win than
the pre-match rating of the teams okay
one more question my question evolution
yes then you are released arenas hello
yeah thanks again for the great talk
before about another application and
maybe what's your opinion about for
example ranking sellers of a specific
product ready what the rating office of
a seller who are specific okay so me I'm
a son shall be fair whatever and could
you apply us core system based on this
so to identify who is the best seller in
your history who gave you the best price
the best will give you the best price
because MVM me from a trading desk and
so we don't have the opportunity to ask
all vendors all the time because then
they get the idea that we want to sell
something unless we want to buy
something so we restricted to ask maybe
two or five and we would like to have a
scoring system who was the best when
yes every time you ask them your updates
your belief about how good a price drink
going to give you yeah because we're
gonna prize from them but we can't ask
everybody yeah so if you assume that
they're going to treat you the same way
no matter for which item you ask the
price I think you should really work
okay so we definitely try it out and I
mean it's quite quite simple to try this
also just give it a go thank you so does
anyone have an idea why this happens
with buying over there please shout loud
yeah yes correct correct because they
didn't lose so many games four in a row
that they've been we're ready really
really high if you look at the entire
lettuce head then this is pie um so yes
they have this little drop but it
doesn't they lose one kilos lot of
points due to this que behavior but
they're still very very outranking
everybody else even when Dortmund wins
the league
okay so thank you very much and a big
applause for that